Tonight another terrorist attack was committed on the bridge,
civilians were killed, civilians were injured and left without
parents, the child
thyme was traveling to Crimea from the Belgorod
region. I ask both the leadership of this
region and the federal authorities
to provide all necessary assistance to the
injured girl and her relatives and
to take this issue into special attention.  control due
to the terrorist attack, the
road surface on several spans of the
Crimean Bridge was seriously damaged, as a result,
road and
rail traffic was temporarily stopped, taking into account the fact
that the second terrorist attack on the Crimean Bridge is taking place
between specific proposals
to improve the security of this
strategically important transport
facility, we wanted to complete today  I would like to
say here What to repeat is that
what happened is another
terrorist act of the
Kiev regime.
This crime is senseless from a military
point of view and has no
significance since the Crimean Bridge has
not been used for military transportation for a long time
and is cruel because
innocent civilians were killed,
father on the Russian side. Of course  the
Ministry of Defense is preparing a
corresponding proposal